hey everybody its Jesse and I'm back
after being sick most of the week still
not a hundred percent so today's stream
will probably be shorter than normal
I'm thinking like maybe an hour or less
I'm gonna do my best my throat hurts a
bit so I do have some tea here so if you
hear a slurping noise that's me sipping
my tea and I'm pretty tired so this may
be equal more of a relaxed type of
stream today but I guess I'm gonna start
out by going over some of the pool
requests that I got quickly and then
we'll see I left off working on getting
a logo and the title to look right so it
just needs a little bit more adjustment
and then I think it'll be okay so maybe
we'll finish that up and see how much
time we have left
also I want to say thank you to everyone
a lot of you either on Twitter or in the
slack channel said let me know you were
concerned or you're praying for me
everything so I really appreciate that I
was really I mean oh that was nice
I wasn't feeling well and to see all
that support from all of you that was
that was really cool so I appreciate
that and also some really awesome news
the freaka camp channel now has over two
hundred thousand subscribers so really
excited about that
that was cool I've been keeping an eye
on it lately
me because it was getting close to 2000
and I was just waiting for it and it it
happened at some point while I was sick
I just noticed that yesterday but that's
really cool so thank you to everyone who
who's subscribed I feel kind of proud
that maybe I've contributed a bit with
my with my live streams to subscribers
and there's a lot of other great people
that do the do videos on this channel as
well and they're responsible for for
most of those subscribers but that's
really cool that's that's a lot of
people so hopefully we keep growing
because I think this channel has a lot
of really great information to help
people learn how to code so the more
people that know about it the better off
they'll be alright hey everyone I see I
see some of you in the live chat now
cool thanks thanks yes John John said
you live streams rock thanks thanks
thanks Blake I appreciate I appreciate
everybody's in saying hi hey how's it
goin all right so let's I'm gonna try
really hard to stay focused so I guess
I'm pretty I'm pretty tired
hopefully the caffeine in this tea will
help help me wake up a bit more as well
alright so there were a lot of changes
and we had to pull requests that I think
we only had to yeah I don't I don't
think I pulled any in while I was at
home I was kind of out of it so I tried
not to do that much coding so I didn't
mess anything up I did work on a project
for my react course which I didn't
really get that much accomplished on
redux is
confusing me quite a bit right now I'm
sure I'll get it I think keep working on
it
but anyway
Nathaniel submitted one pull request and
he added added to the get ignore which
is awesome and very useful so thank you
for that and then I guess the next pull
request is really huge so I'm not really
gonna go over it all because it would be
so much I guess I just kind of really
briefly summarized some of what was in
it and you can check it out I'm double
check on my other screen with the number
of that pull request was I'm pretty sure
it was 50 yeah so poor requests 50 is
quite large so just from from memory I'm
going to try to sum this up sorry if I
miss anything and this is from Matt a
lot of the data so basic strategies are
less now so there's more components so
you have a few more components now we
have all these data files also another
change is matt has switched out the
regular map for lodash this map and he
links you could check it out in the in
the pool request he provides a link to
comparison as to which one's faster
which is cool
the only thing I'm I just noticed I
didn't notice this when I was pulling
this in and I just noticed it a few
minutes ago was it looks like we're in
forwarding all of lodash and so it might
be better since we're only using as far
as I can tell yep in this component
we're only using
we could probably just import map I mean
that's like a really really small if you
look at the low - github repo to import
map it's I don't know like the entire
file is like less than 50 lines and 80%
of it or it's just comments explaining
what it does so it'd be really small
amount of code to import instead of
everything so I'll probably change that
at some point if somebody really wants
to get a pull request and on your github
profile maybe you know you just starting
out that would be something really easy
just look up how to on low - this
documentation how to just import that -
switch it over I think it's not just map
though I think filter is also replaced
where we are using it so we're not are
we using it here we're not using it here
but anywhere we're using filter then
filter will need to be pulled in as well
so maybe I'll if I remember maybe I'll
open up a an issue kind of explaining
that and then that way you all can let
me know what you think about it as well
okay so let me show you what I've done
so I I did make sure to update the repo
before before I started the stream so
everything should be up-to-date on
github I I think I may have forgotten to
update the repo at the end of Monday
stream so sorry about that if I did I
guess I could scroll back up through my
terminal to double-check but anyway this
basically I was just working on this
this is where we left off before so you
could see I right now I have resource
center over here to the right we now
have this menu icon
is visible and working and then our logo
is here the only thing that needs
changes when I move this over here for
some reason it just made the header a
lot taller than it needs to be so I'd
like to shrink this up a little bit move
everything up and then I think it'll be
I think it'll look all right I'm not I
really like this I like I like the logo
I think that looks nice
I'm not exactly sure what to do with
this so that's why I just put it over
here and in any case we'll have to
figure out what to do on a small screen
because you know that's that's not what
we want so still have some things to
decide but I think this looks it looks
good enough at this point fine you know
if we have time we can always adjust
that more later on
okay
oh cool I just checked the live chat
really quickly and it looks like Matt
Matt your MFC 88 right I'm pretty sure
you are sorry if I'm forgetting things I
am out of it I'm usually pretty good
about remembering what everybody's
handles are in YouTube then anyway Matt
offered to help with redux Thanks
oh okay cool oh I may be asking you a
question i yes i really like i read
through so much documentation on
I think Tuesday when I was - I I just
sat in a recliner with my laptop and
like took naps and read Redux
documentation pretty much all day so yes
I'll be asking about that and thanks for
offering to help Sebastian set us I
should add some margin left to poster
resources and poster okay yep yeah I
should probably have this line up on all
the pages with this I'm not sure why
it's not lining up right now after look
I probably just don't have it within the
same container or something
okay so first let's get this let's get
this to a point where we like how it
looks and then we'll go from there so
since this was when I added this that's
when this got a lot taller then I'm
gonna start by looking here to see
what's going on with the the margins and
padding and it's probably something to
do with with padding let me make this a
bit smaller
and should be able to see as I hover
over will be able to see the margins and
in orange okay so we definitely have
some more margin that we need going on
okay and our div also has just some
default default margin so I guess we
could actually I think that divs
auto-generated so it's gonna be a bit
more difficult to get to this div so
let's just worry about the h1 when I
when I say auto-generated I mean this
div is added in and in one of the
material I components so I don't really
have direct access to it cuz I don't I
don't want to edit the components
directly so tojust and there's no unique
identifier here so it'll be a lot easier
just to try to adjust this h1 which I'm
passing in this h1 so I can put styles
right on that it's the only h1 on the
page so I can even reference that right
in the sass file and I know it'll just
it will apply here yeah so let's just
try to get rid of all the margin and see
if we'll see what it looks like
okay so with margin zero that's not
terrible it looks like it's not it's not
exactly centered though
it's a
yes
so I'm checking this out I'm not sure
why why this div
is bigger
okay yes it doesn't matter
if we add
now I may have to actually edit this div
let's see let's just shut it let's add a
bit of margin on the top I want to see
if it would basically what I want to
happen is to push this down without
making the header bigger what I think
might happen is the header will just get
pushed down hopefully not but we'll give
it a shot
oh nice awesome so cool I don't really
like trying to eyeball this and just
guess at it being centered I could I
could probably do some math and get it a
little bit closer but that that looks
about right we can zoom in a bit
maybe so not letting me zoom in that's
weird well for some reason I can't zoom
you know normally you could if you have
a Mac you know you could zoom in with
the track that can't do it okay well at
least that that works though so if we go
with margin
when we end up with five okay five pics
back let me do it let me do it in the
code I think we had it a nap yeah so I
already have some styles on that h1 so
let's go with margin and five for the
top top right bottom left
all right awesome okay so yeah I'm still
not 100% sure about this being over here
but we'll go for it for now another
I guess an alternative that I have seen
is we probably have to really change how
this this bar works and maybe make our
own component but you can have so like
the menu can still stay out out here on
the side but the logo and the title
would be within these bounds of the
container so the maximum you know
there's there's a max width here I can't
remember what it is maybe 2000 pixels so
they would stay here within those bounds
that might look better yeah this looks
at the very least it needs a bit more
margin I think which let's add that in
well what we have this up that's add 8
pixels
let's see
all right that's better at least it
doesn't get covered up
okay not bad
then I check the live chat quickly just
to see what you all think
okay John makes a good point well
several good points I'm gonna read one
of them out it says because you're using
the font size control on with the width
of the screen that margin might align
differently at different widths I
actually I don't think I'm using it for
this one so let me let me make sure
unless you were talking about this one
instead which I think I am using that I
guess responsive font for that one and I
actually on this page I do have this
aligned so probably earlier Sebastian
had mentioned that this heading was kind
of outside the bounds of where all the
rest of the content was on another page
something on posters so you can see that
here so I'm I'm almost positive now that
I saw the other page is it's just a
matter of where I put this H SH - of
whether or not I put it inside the same
container so that'll be an easy fix
okay well let's let's commit this and
then move on we still have just have a
good amount of time left or not even a
half hour in so move on to something
else and was my it is check it out what
did we change posters yep that's what I
wanted to change and
see I don't know what I changed him
posters touch ass oh you know what I
changed some was it I changed something
earlier right before I started the
stream and I hadn't committed that yet
so that's what it is we're gonna commit
this we're going to use am flag so that
we can commit and add and put a message
at the same time so let's say just title
margins yeah that works
all right great pass all the tests made
it through linting so now we can get
mastered all right awesome
so now but let's let's go and since
since Sebastian brought it up let's fix
this so if anyone has any objections to
this being aligned here if for some
reason you think it looks better being a
few pixels to the left let me know
quickly before I start changing it
otherwise I'm going to proceed with
adjusting it where wherever this is this
problem is found
mmm
yeah it looks like Sebastian you're
you're absolutely right that's what I
was just checking out as well the h2
should be inside a column and then it
will give everything the the correct
alignment let's see just put this in a
column actually I I usually do try to
put things in columns because I have had
problems with this before with similar
issues I guess I just was I don't know
what I was thinking there maybe I was
just trying to go quickly and just get
something on a page that's probably
probably would happen Wow I am really
and I want to start off okay
oh man I can't even copy and paste today
there we go
all right awesome so it fixes that so
just go through quickly and see if it's
doing that on any other pages
let's check out huh yep it's doing it on
home so let's see
all right logos hmm
okay planning guide
okay
okay well I'm trying to look this is
this component is really different than
it was before the last pull request so
kind of figure out where everything is
anything guidelines
all right
all right great and already have an
English only one more page
it's a glossary page this I'm not sure
I'm just gonna check that page yep
it's not
all right awesome
okay so that should be all the pages so
now we have consistency there so thanks
for bringing that up Sebastian I do have
a question in the live chat so I'm just
going to take this question right now
since I forgot to set my timer right now
it would be if I had set my timer at the
beginning it would be right about the
time where I'd take my 5 minutes to look
at the live chat so I'm gonna do that so
how what says I'm starting college this
year and want to get into programming I
just started practicing yesterday on
free code camp so I'm excited to see
where I go with this Oh awesome
sorry I thought it was a question I
didn't read the whole thing first
anyway that's that's really cool my my
wife actually just started free code
camp within the last week or so she's
going to try to do the hundred days of
code and it's kind of cool it's my wife
was not released my wife's an English
professor so not really into coding
before but it's kind of cool to be able
to go through and and help her out with
some of the exercises so so she's going
through the same thing you just starting
out with it so I hope you stick with it
and let me know if you if you need any
help or encouragement with anything
all right I don't think there's any
other questions I'm going to scroll
through quickly
digital dolly game says free code camp
needs to make c-sharp tutorials I don't
know if there's any plans to do any
c-sharp tutorials if it happens it's not
going to be me because I have very
limited experience with she C sharp so
you can't can't really give you a much
hope of that right now not there's no
snow plans that I know of that maybe
somebody's working on it and I just
don't know
oh cool Alberto says that he started
recording some some coding sessions in
c-sharp he's not not comfortable about
releasing it yet
Umberto's especially since I'm nowhere
near the quality of Jessi dev tips
traversing media and all the other
already established face so I'm bear to
the fact that you mentioned me in the
same sentence as dev tips makes me just
super happy because I because I love the
deficits show and yeah so if I'm like if
in your mind I'm anywhere close to to
that caliber of show then that's a
really big compliment for me so I
appreciate that
and also I would say I mean don't worry
so much about whether or not something's
ready to be released
hmm sorry
yawning getting really tired
yeah don't worry so much about whether
you're ready if you know I like I don't
know when I started I didn't really
practice if anybody goes like to my my
own channel my personal channel and
watch this on my first streams they're
not good I couldn't get the settings
right
and so the quality's bad
so yeah it's and I think for some of the
videos that the font was so small you
couldn't even see it at all so sometimes
you figure that out and yeah I mean I
guess I kind of feel bad if people try
to go back and watch that watch those
first videos the quality is bad but you
know like really quickly you catch on so
anyway I think it's just cool it's more
encouragement if you actually have the
stuff out there and you can get feedback
from people and encouragement from those
people then you'll be more likely to
stick with it I know if I had just like
recorded my my stuff and watched it
myself before I actually put it out
there I probably would have been too
self-conscious about it to actually post
it but instead just on the live stream
it it doesn't give me a chance to
second-guess myself because it's already
out there which in my case ends up being
a good thing because then I get my stuff
out there and in it otherwise wouldn't
be
oh okay really quickly I'm going to
address this I just saw some of the
conversation that was happening when I
was answering things previewed that were
up near the top of the live chat someone
trying to fun whoo chaos 2 is using next
Jas with create react which I've never
heard of that
well
yeah I would say so Sebastian said check
the previous project yes if you check
out the previous project that was with
next jazz so yeah I've actually never
heard of anyone using both before I
would imagine that it there's there's
probably an easier way to do that you
would only really need to use one or the
other depending on what you need
Patrick says the difference between you
and dev tips is that he edits out
periods where he is stuck yeah I wonder
how long my streams would really be if I
edit it out all the times I messed up I
would have five minute videos Umberto's
says I just don't want to get bad
information I want to be able to do the
thing where I stress that this is it's
just I am showing how to do it but it's
difficult to do when I feel like there's
a better correct way to do things
yeah I'm Bert oh I am I definitely
understand that I feel the same way too
I I do really want to show so I I there
are a lot of times when there's not
necessarily a correct way but there are
some ways that maybe better than others
it depends on what your goal is in your
particular requirements for that project
but I I definitely understand that and I
I feel bad if I say something that I
later find out was not the right way to
do things and so I do try to mention
that but I I realized that you know not
everybody watches every minute of every
stream so there are going to be people
who probably watch something in an
earlier stream and never realize that
I've corrected it later on and at this
point there's just so many streams it
would be really hard to go back and
correct everything so I totally
understand that but I think like you say
if you just give I mean I frequently
give the disclaimer that you know this
is just me doing this you know the best
way I know how
with with all you help from all of you
you know if people understand that
coming in that that's that that's what's
going on here then I may I feel better
about it at least you know I don't I
don't claim that this is a tutorial you
know
so anyway but totally up to you
certainly if you feel comfortable or not
but it would be cool you know to see
them so let me know when you when you do
release them I'd like to check them out
I said not really into doing anything
with c-sharp but we do run some things
with c-sharp here at the University I
don't work on them but it'd be cool to
know a little bit more about them just
to understand how things how things work
because occasionally I do have to help
like like right now we're we're down one
developer in the department that works
on the c-sharp stuff so I have to help
occasionally if something is like an
emergency and really needs done alright
so let's a sh says hey can we ask
questions if we don't understand
something yes definitely
yeah so I'm gonna do some more coding
but before I end I'm gonna go back
through and see if there's any questions
and and I'll answer them all before I
finish the stream so let's do some more
I'm not let's see how about I could for
about ten more minutes and then I do
questions and then that way I'll be I'll
be finished in about an hour which I
just don't want to push it cuz I don't
want to lose my voice and I'm getting
tired so I think the quality of my
coding is going to go down quickly I can
already feel it's like it's hard to
focus
all right I guess I should figure out
what I'm gonna change first see that
talking about that focus he difficult
all right let me think of something that
I can get done in ten minutes I guess I
could check my shell award
I guess that's done I'll double-check it
I'll put it here
actually let's let's work on this
because I think this is really
interesting and I've never tried this
before and I have no idea if I can get
it done in ten minutes but I'd like to
just check it out so we before we had we
set up our file upload and it's giving
us a list and it was someone maybe
Sebastian had had got this working and I
think he was the one that suggested this
I'm not 100% sure so sorry if I'm giving
credit to the wrong person but let me
show you what we're talking about so in
our upload files lists you upload a few
okay so we have I guess I need more
that's a lot of them ok so right now it
gets cut off and you can't see the rest
right you can't do anything about it so
it'd be cool to scroll normally I'm not
a huge fan of horizontal scrolling but
in this case it makes sense it makes
more sense I think than having them
wrapped because that would just mess up
the spacing too so let's try to do a
horizontal scroll hopefully this is as
simple as just setting the overflow and
if that's the case we can definitely get
this done so let's see there we go
but
hmmm let's shout out overflow
no she's not working I I doubt it would
work to put it on here but let's let's
try it actually we did have the
overflow:hidden no no it's not working
and not really anything else I could do
about that huh
okay so this is just a text input and
the only it's only job is just to hold
these values right now so what if we
made it a multi-line text input it might
wrap then right so it would be what a
text area instead of an input
let's uh let's try that I'm not sure
about it like I said because that might
end up changing the spacing but if I
can't get the horizontal scroll then
that's the next best thing I'll have to
make sure see class file path hopefully
everything is referencing this class
name so that if I keep the same class
name it should still work but yes
there's one way to find out let's just
do it much use that service requests
okay so yeah there's a lot to this
okay here's our file upload and there we
go here's our input okay
oops
textarea and do we need a type on the
tech series
and I think we do
see oh goodness
well that that looks really ugly I'm not
worried about that right now I'm just
kind of worried about if it works what
we'll need to do is is use the material
UI excuse me let me tear you eye
component for this instead of just
changing its a text area some files
hmm
all right well
that of course is not what we want but
what should happen though if we're using
this type of text arias it should expand
so I'm hoping that we'll get it to
expand like that
let's see
oops let's go back and text field okay
I'm just gonna copy this and remove what
we don't need
let's get rid of this
okay
Suter looks like not dopes
I never removed this one
okay need some adjustment but doesn't
look that bad so far
yay all right that's so much better all
right I like that I like that and I'm
not super worried about the spacing like
I thought I would be basically because
the odds of some of the uploading this
many files are slim so not that many
people will even see it but even then it
doesn't look terrible
below is a whole new section so it would
look a lot it would look weird if let's
say it was right in the middle of here
where you do have a uniform spacing and
then all of a sudden it would change but
because this space here only happens
once it doesn't really seem like it's
messed up now what I would like to do is
make in relation to this upload button
have this aligned a little bit better at
the very least I want to have the top of
this lined up with the top of this
button probably best thing would be to
have it centered but not bad and that
works
and I think do you need to double-check
where else am i I don't think I'm that
will affect anything else I was just
kind of wondering about when I get all
the values to send out in the email and
send our project management system well
I think it should be fine because it's
the same eating the value from a text
area and from an input field is the same
as opposed to like getting a checkbox
value or something okay that's cool I
like that my timer went off so I'm gonna
answer some questions now and off
probably before I leave today I'll clean
this up a bit and then commit that as
well as I don't think I committed this
yet where we lined up all of these up so
I'll do that too
and then that way everything on github
will be up to date
okay ash asks are there any repos of
these projects on github or bitbucket I
want to compare with my code to see if
I'm doing something wrong and Joseph did
say look in the description yeah so if
if you want to follow along this is on
github I do have the links in the
descriptions to all the videos so feel
free to check it out use it I have a few
people who let me know that they're
using what I'm doing on this project or
the last project as the basis for one of
their projects and I think that's
awesome so yeah so feel free and okay
Sebastian I mentioned early I thought it
was Sebastian that had had done the the
upload thing maybe it's not maybe it was
Kevin yeah it was really early on it was
a while ago so I can't remember exactly
but we'll say keV I don't think Kevin's
in the live chat now so we'll just say
it was Kevin he can't he can't let us
know
I think Kevin hasn't been around the
live set for a while he's working on his
own project and he sent me a message a
few days ago telling me about it so it's
cool hopefully he'll get it to the point
where he can share that and if he lets
me maybe I can share a link with you all
let's see like we have some more
question here we go
ash ash hey just by the way Jesse what's
your coding background like did you go
to uni or are you self-taught so yeah I
do have a bachelor's degree but it's in
business
so I I took I did complete one C++
programming course but so that's the
extent of my formal education maybe I
did take a class in high school where we
spent a couple weeks on basic HTML but I
don't know that that really counts but
other than that it's just been all
online and mostly free resources I think
I spent maybe $30 on udemy courses and
until very recently until a few months
ago when I signed up for the react nano
degree like I literally had spent 30
dollars or less on courses the entire
time that I've been doing this so big
you know years I had spent that so which
I I say that because it's it's really I
think it's a really cool thing about
this industry that someone with very
little in terms of financial resources
can learn enough and get a job doing
this which I think that's awesome
because so many other fields are like
it's just hard to break into unless
you're already wealthy because the cost
to get in you know I'm thinking like if
you want to be a doctor or a lawyer
unless you want to go into a lot of debt
you just you can't you can't do it you
know you need me need so much money to
be able to go go to school for that many
years to get that the education you need
so anyway I did give a also on my
channel there's a link in the
description that I think there's a link
in the description to my channel
otherwise you can just look up Jesse
Weigel and it should come up
on YouTube search but I did a video kind
of going through my history of learning
to be a front-end developer so if you
want to know more check that out it's
not it's not super long I think it's
like 10 minutes so it's not really
in-depth but it'll give you kind of a
nice overview of where I came from and
how I got to where I am now
ooh ooh Paul says business decoding so
good that's pretty great yeah actually I
don't I don't think I said this on a
stream before or in my video but I guess
I'll take the last minute here just to
say this it may it may be helpful to
somebody so when I was a teenager
I had thought about doing coding I was
always really good with computers and a
lot of people said you know why don't
you do computers I have an uncle who's a
programmer and you know he would talk to
me about it and I had decided I didn't
want to do computers because I thought
if I did computers I would just be stuck
in a cubicle all day and I wouldn't get
to talk to anybody and that would be my
life I if you've ever seen the first
Matrix movie where the main character
that's literally he has this tiny little
cubicle and he just types on his
keyboard all day and it's it's terrible
so that's the idea I had in my mind of
what I would do and I said no like I
don't really want to do that now
hopefully probably some of you were
laughing when you hear that because
that's not at all what this is right so
I had a mistaken view of what what this
was all about and I probably would have
been in this a lot earlier had I had I
had a better view of things you know I
mean now it seems were crazy because now
you have like it's well known that
Google's offices are really cool and you
know I don't know things have changed I
think in terms of the perception of what
what coding is but you know at least
when I was a teenager it wasn't like
that so anyway so that's why I ended up
going into business and because but I
really
was kind of into coding and they thought
about it earlier so it's kind of cool
that I ended up back here in the end and
although I am actually sitting in an
office by myself right now I'm talking
to all of you so it's not like I'm
somehow chained to a cubicle or anything
like that anyway so I guess the the
moral of my story if there is one is
especially for those of you maybe who
are younger this would be more helpful
but don't don't dismiss something some
you know a job or anything that you have
interest in you know without really
checking it out you know so like see if
you can get an internship or like shadow
somebody who does that job you know to
really find out what it's like because
now that I'm doing this I love it and it
would have been really cool if I could
have been doing this then you know some
of the other jobs that I've had if
nothing so great so I would have much
rather done this then then the other
things that I've done so anyway I think
that's I've got all the questions so I'm
gonna wrap things up and probably get
out of here early and go take a nap I
guess if mike my kids let me feel I was
thinking that but oh well it's already
Friday I was gonna say I'll see you
tomorrow but it's it's Friday the whole
week's been messed up for me I'm really
thinking about it now it is Friday right
yeah I just checked my calendar okay
uh-huh so I will see you all on Monday
and have a great weekend hopefully I'll
be back to a hundred percent by Monday
and I can get some some real work done
on this thank you all so much for
watching for all your help and have a
great weekend